[Music]
this video sponsored by kog games their
game Kurt's bar is an anime style action
based game from a third-person
perspective players can battle it out in
both PvP and PvE mission based battle
modes with massive boss monsters they've
just released their new update ethica
and a new character the sacred guardian
lime for Kog fans the character limes
easily recognized as the cute
heavy-hitting paladin styled hammer
wielding innocent young girl from their
cult classic game grand chase I mean
personally I'm really enjoying the game
and would recommend you to check out the
link in the description and download the
game for free it's October and you know
what time it is time for Halloween in
celebration of the spooks and scares I
present to you this very special edition
of the top 10 list can you guess what it
is
if you guessed top 10 horror anime step
up and claim your prize it's actually
quite a no-brainer though isn't it
really as you guessed we'll be taking a
look at ten a very special horror anime
however we won't necessarily be going
through anime that will strike fear by
being outright scary so no jump scares
for you on this one thank goodness
instead the entries on the list strike
fear in various different ways mainly
body and psychological horror
do you dare dive into this realm of
horror anime if you're ready let's go
[Music]
vampires open our list with the 2010
anime Shiki an adaptation of a manga
based on a horror novel Shiki takes
place in a village that falls victim to
a serious epidemic a natural death begin
to occur and a doctor Ozaki and troubled
youth Yuki team up to solve the mystery
plaguing the village the way the show
structured reminds me of classic horror
shows actually with a modern vampire
show in anime often becoming superpower
fest with a touch of romance it's
refreshing to see a show that sticks
these bloodsuckers to the old horror
routine instead of focusing on cool
powers or action-packed survival plots
reminiscent of arcade rail shooter games
Shiki takes things slowly and
methodically focusing more on ethical
and moral dilemmas for the audience to
digest being scary is subjective but
shaky certainly filled with unsettling
images especially with the character
designs those are creepy is that you
don't stare into for then haunt you
throughout the night at number 9 is
memories memories is quite complicated
instead of an anime series it's an
anthology of short films magnetic Rose
stink bomb and cannon fodder these films
tell stories in hindsight about
seemingly unrelated incidents think
Fantasia for a closer comparison if I
would have to name one after all how can
you connect a sci-fi mystery with black
comedy and something more symbolic
individually the three films boasts
impressive animation for its time as
well as a taste for atmosphere magnetic
Rose is the best among the three of them
it shouldn't be surprising since the
legendary Satoshi Kon wrote the script
the reason why the movie's here is
because Nightmare fuel just scattered
all across the movies from the Haunted
spaceship to the visuals of terrorist
attacks memory certainly fits the horror
genre the art star adds a lot more to
this horrifying atmosphere and while
memories is probably not scary in the
traditional sense everything seems a lot
harsher in hindsight
[Music]
[Music]
our eighth title is paprika the
dreamworld is interesting isn't it
hidden deep in the human psyche are a
person's deepest desires and secrets
scientists have created a device that
allows a person to access dreams and
record them it sounds cool doesn't it
unfortunately the device named DC mini
also opens the floodgates to possible
forms of psychological attacks on people
naturally of course things go wrong and
one of the prototypes of the machine
goes missing the catch here is that the
prototype doesn't have the protection
system which protects people's minds
from being hacked
thus it falls to dr. Chiba and paprika's
hands to protect the world from a whole
new form of terrorism even in reality
the world of dreams is in the world that
I would gladly venture into now imagine
it being visualized in anime form and
it's a no brainer that paprika is
included on this list the visuals of
dolls in the movie would surely haunt
the dreams of the unprepared and that's
just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to the Tipsy product this movie is
this isn't the last you'll see of
Satoshi Kon on the list not by a long
shot
for our Lucky seven we look at perfect
blue immediately we have another Satoshi
Kon creation perfect blues a movie about
me Marc Illinois a member of an idol
group who pursues a solo career the
decision to go into acting is tough
enough already but add in compromising
photo shoots a stroker and a series of
murders to the mix and then you have
yourself a benchmark psychological
thriller the line between fantasy and
reality gets blurred and you start
seeing the signature Satoshi Kon mind
[ __ ] that's made him a renowned
personality in the industry the movie
features lots of blood violence and
other scenes that you wouldn't want to
watch with kids this is filled with
gruesome scenes and it isn't a movie for
the faint-hearted but if you're one of
the people looking through this list in
order to find anime that would satisfy
your thirst for horror then you've hit
the jackpot with this 1/6 on our list is
Mononoke not to be confused with the
popular movie that shares its name
Mononoke the TV series is a spin-off of
a horror anthology it follows the
medicine seller who travels to Japan in
search of evil spirits called Mononoke
however he can't just slay the spirit
despite being a master of the occult
before he can slay one he has to first
discover the spirits form origin and
motive first thing you might notice
about the series is its art style is
certainly not the typical style that
you'd expect from anime and this series
utilizes it excellently the anime is
filled with vibrant colors and an
overall ambiance that resembles
something that you'd expect from ancient
Japanese artwork it also allows the
animation team to showcase their talent
in depicting supernatural creatures and
all sorts of Horrors overall Mononoke is
an interesting watch that might not be
everyone's cup of tea but trust me when
I say that it is definitely worth a shot
[Applause]
[Music]
entering at number five is from the new
world shin sekai yuri from the new world
in english is a story of a futuristic
utopia except it doesn't even look
sci-fi at all apparently modern society
as we know it hasn't been replaced by
steampunk buildings and high-tech
gadgets you heard that right our
protagonist Saki Watanabe lives in an
isolated village in a world ruled by
psychic powers after obtaining her
powers the next step is to enter an
academy with the aim of owning her
skills
however the question soon surfaces what
about the children who don't awaken
their powers also what about the cap
that abduct children looks like the
world is a lot darker than we thought it
would be at first glance this show got
me at first I thought it was just a
run-of-the-mill seasonal show around
half a decade ago and that it wouldn't
be full of scary moments but here we are
with the show that's unafraid to kill
off key characters show off some
unsettling imagery reveal scary monsters
and attack us with nightmare inducing
sequences plot twist after plot twist
brilliant imagery and morally thought
inducing plot lines made from the new
world a must watch among the twenty
twelve shows
[Music]
did you know that four is the number of
death in Japan how fitting that our
fourth entry is Higurashi when they cry
if you've been watching anime for some
time you know better by now than to get
fooled by first impressions when they
cry starts off as what you'd expect from
one of those harem visual novels hey
Ichi moves to a province where he meets
several girls and starts befriending
them all's well and everyone's happy in
this rural setting but of course
something soon goes wrong doesn't it
every four years a murder happens in the
village as the mystery starts to unfold
it turns out that the key suspects are
not closer to our protagonist than you'd
expect I've been saying this for the
past few titles but this one is
definitely not for the faint-hearted
it's a murder mystery series and it's
not afraid to get down and dirty when it
comes to depictions of such heinous acts
I dare say that when they cry would give
stuff like even gongyuan a run for its
money
as far as insane mind racking scenes and
overall creepiness goes the first in the
top three is probably something you'd
expect for me it's by far the most
action-packed and thrilling among the
entries
it's parasite we can't have a top three
list without the king of body horror one
night spores fall to earth carrying with
them alien organisms called parasites
infecting humans get taken over gaining
the ability to transform their bodies
with an appetite for fellow humans
however one parasite was unsuccessful in
taking over its intended host high
school student Shinichi zoomy stuck on
his right arm
McGee's forced to form an uneasy
alliance with its hosts as the duo fight
to survive a world where danger lurks in
every corner it's got action field
fights exciting chase scenes and a
varied arsenal of body horror
Shinichi and McGee's combination fights
feature a lot of creative uses of the
parasite arm if you're in for body
horror and thrilling fights this is an
anime you shouldn't miss
[Music]
front runner up we have a fairly recent
anime the promised Neverland now a first
glance
life a grace filled house may see more
sunshine and butterflies it's an
orphanage where children live happily
with their mom Isabella what could
possibly go wrong everything now without
spoiling too much something really
messed up is going on in this orphanage
finding the truth about the orphanage a
trio of kids Emma Norman and Rey work
together to get orphans to escape the
grisly fate that awaits them the premise
seems dark enough but I'd personally
classify this series as a thriller than
a horror show nevertheless it has a lot
of gripping scenes that keep you on God
when I watched it I was amazed by its
masterful use of visuals and sound to
create an ominous atmosphere you almost
expect something to pop out only for it
then to be nothing and then all of a
sudden a camera ship will happen which
would quickly catch you off guard with a
jump scare this anime is sure to leave
you at the edge of your seats
[Music]
standing atop yet another list is an
anime that's been refitted making its
return from the top ten mystery-thriller
list we cap off with monster now with
the title like that did you expect to
see this show maker return if you're
still not familiar with how the plot
goes here's the rundown the story it
stars dr. Ken's open MA a surgeon who
decides against protocol to operate on a
dying boy Yohan Leibert now the to
reunite years later but not as doctor
and patient as doctor and murderer with
a guilt of helping create this monster
Tenma goes after the boy he once saved
now to be honest monster isn't as scary
as the other titles on the list as far
as the traditional definition of horror
goes I mean no jump scares demons
dismembering human corpses or violent
deaths or exploding heads or anything
like that however it attacks way deeper
than visual horror it strikes fear in
our hearts by simply illustrating how
horrible the human being can be like the
show's protagonist we've perhaps had
that lingering feeling of being
responsible for some of the most
degenerate Horrors imaginable to man
have we somewhere along the line helped
create an uncontainable evil that lurks
a lot closer to home than we imagined
it's a question that begs pondering from
some of us well that's a wrap have yet
your share of anime horror yep don't be
afraid to drop some recommendations and
I'll gladly check some of them out if
you have requests for future top-ten
lists or suggestions for slightly
different content feel free to voice out
through the comments section below we
also appreciate any feedback you have if
you enjoyed the video like share and
subscribe if you'd like to support the
channel please consider joining the
channel membership I'd really appreciate
it don't forget to check out our
sponsors game Kurtz Belle links in the
description I'll see you next time on
vinnie tube
[Music]